Winter break?
Who needs breaks?
In America, we work until our
hearts give out, literally.
Hey everyone, Laci
Green here for DNews.
Winter break is upon
us, a time of year
when people hold up
and take a breather.
But surely there should be
more than one time of the year
that we take a break, right?
Otherwise, you start
to get a little loony.
You wouldn't think
that we need time off
by looking at the statistics.
Americans receive an average
of 14 vacation days per year
from their employer.
And they only took up about
10 of those days last year.
That leaves over
a half a billion--
that's right billion with a B--
vacation hours unused in 2012.
Why wouldn't people take
their vacation time?
This is an absurdity, a tragedy.
In a study by Expedia,
the most common reason
people couldn't get away
was because, well, work
got in the way.
You saw that one
coming, didn't you?
But it's strange.
I mean, it's not like 14 days is
some grand break to begin with.
Two weeks out of 52?
In the European
Union, workers are
guaranteed at least four
weeks of vacation time.
And those are paid
days, unlike the US.
The USA is actually
the only country
of the 20 most advanced
economies in the world that
doesn't require workers
have paid time off.
Paid time off, including
holidays, in the private sector
averages 16 days,
which is less than
is required by law in all
19 of the other countries.
The fact that many workers
don't get paid time off
may contribute to the
pattern of Americans
not taking a vacation.
They can't afford to
take time off work
or they feel like it's
not really worth it.
No pay while you're
away and you also
have to pay out of pocket
expenses to take a vacation.
Effectively, vacation could
cost two to three times as much.
Amongst the kindest
countries toward vacationing
are France, Spain, Belgium,
New Zealand, and Germany.
But Austria and Portugal
come out on top.
Both guarantee five weeks in
paid vacations and holidays,
the most in the world.
Austrian workers, however,
work even fewer hours
than the Portuguese.
And they have almost double
the labor productivity
and GDP per capita.
That said, the US has even
higher labor productivity,
which some might
use as an argument
for never taking a vacation.
The problem is that France and
Germany, two other countries
with 30 plus days off, have
comparable labor outcomes
to the US.
The other problem
with that argument
is, of course, that
vacation is friggin awesome.
As the number of hours that
we work goes up and up,
it's important to take
a step back and remember
to live our lives man.
You're not getting any younger.
And vacationing has been
linked with a number
of positive effects.
The obvious being
breaking the stress cycle,
which allows us to
relax and renew,
rejuvenating motivation
and creativity.
Stress is a sneaky one.
It's a lot harder on the
body than it might seem.
Stress relief is vital to
a good quality of life.
A new study has also
found that traveling
is linked to a decreased
risk of heart disease, heart
attacks, and depression.
All of this and more is why
pretty much every country
in the developed
world makes sure
that its people
can take a break.
After all, happy workers
are productive workers.
So America, when are you
going to get with the program?
Thanks for joining me
for DNews everyone.
How much vacation time do you
take every year where you live?
Tell me about it down below.
And we'll see you next time.